[Applause]
[Music]
singing loud and proud that is the Del
Sol Academy singers from of course Del
Sol high school so they are gearing up
really for the performance of a lifetime
or could be this summer New York City at
the iconic Carnegie Hall but as Ryan
Matthey shows us fundraiser for this
lower income school is the one thing
that's standing in the way
from the small stage of Del Sol high
school here to the bright lights of
Carnegie Hall the Del Sol Academy
singers have that opportunity this
summer if they can afford it and to
prevent that note from turning sour
they're asking for your help
laces del Sol's Premiere vocal Ensemble
has hit a high note I was like for like
the real Carnegie Hall like the real one
local studies director Jordan medogamy
oversees nearly 300 singers here
[Music]
the 40 of them getting the chance to
perform in the Big Apple this July with
other High School choirs across the
country and while the notes may not be
sharp the price tag is like September
October there was some like oh we don't
know if we can do this altogether ninety
thousand dollars roughly two grand per
kid a price not all students can afford
the title one School receives federal
dollars to close the gap in academic
achievements between students of all
socioeconomic backgrounds but those
dollars don't cover it all we're doing
something all the time like everywhere
all the time always we've been doing
fundraisers at restaurants we've been
asking for donations from just the local
community putting pressure on already
full pleats once the Bell Rings
sometimes we don't know their story and
I think some of these students not just
at our school but across the valley have
harder lives than we think
just like they're singing their hopes
Crescendo it's Carnegie Hall it's a very
prestigious place and it's only once in
a lifetime opportunity do you think
you'll get there oh we're gonna get
there we're gonna get there for sure